coronavirus hot spots around the US
include New York New Jersey
Massachusetts Michigan and Louisiana
where the governor says the curve could
be starting to flatten Janet shamlian is
at the Louisiana Texas border where
Texas officials are stopping drivers
coming in Janet what exactly is
happening there Anthony good morning so
we're along Interstate 10 drivers are
being diverted off the highway as they
come into Texas they line up here and as
they get to the front of the line
they're being questioned by state
troopers about where they plan to spend
the next 14 days in self-quarantine as
mandated by the governor there are
announced checkpoints like this one at
all major crossings between Louisiana
and Texas it's part of an effort to stop
the spread of the corona virus because
as we know cases in Louisiana are
spiking
most of them in the New Orleans area
where on Monday a 1,000 bed hospital
opened as sort of a makeshift area to
help ease the overcrowding and local
hospitals in that area 1800 more than
1800 new cases reported on Monday that
brings the state's total number of
coronavirus cases to almost 15,000 and
now 512 deaths are reported in the state
of Louisiana on Monday Governor John bel
Edwards released a very sobering
statistic he said of those five hundred
and twelve deaths 70 percent of those
people were African American Gail we're
starting to hear more about that Janet
thank you very much